The entire premise of our republic rests on
an informed citizenry, Americans need to understand
what their government is doing at all the
different levels. Only journalists provide
that service in the interest of the truth.
You can't have freedom without knowledge and
education of what's going on,
and that's what the journalist's job is.
A journalist without integrity can always
find the story he's looking for. Responsible
journalism has to have a broader perspective,
has to have enough of an education to say,
"What we really ought to be looking at is
not what everyone says the story is."
We have a very big, ambitious core curriculum,
and that means that everyone here gets fundamentally
educated. They study the great subjects, they
highest subjects about the highest things.
That gives them tools, first of all, to know
what good writing is, but second, to know
how things that are going on today fit in
the story of the world. We have kids from
every discipline here who are very equipped
to become journalists.
I think Hillsdale provides you with a really
cohesive curriculum. As a journalist, that
helped me become a critical thinker. It helps
me come up with what good questions are.
The Liberal Arts gives you a wide breadth of knowledge
and you kind of get to see the world in lots
of different ways, different philosophies
and studies. That's really important in journalism
to be able to look at one story through every
different angle to understand the motivation
and to put yourself in other people shoes.
John Miller, Head of the Dow Journalism Program
at Hillsdale, is himself an outstanding journalist
and still committing great journalism every
day, every week at National Review. He understands
what makes a story compelling, true, and important.
At the heart of the program is our campus
newspaper, The Collegian. It comes out weekly
during the semesters. You learn journalism
by doing journalism, by going to writing the
stories, doing the interviews, laying them
out on a newspaper page, and then seeing it
come out at the end of the week and watching
students read it and get their reaction.
I love spending Wednesday nights in The Collegian
office. The Editor in Chief and the News
Editor and I, we would work together on stuff
and we'd argue and it would be dramatic. I
have really fond memories of this now because
it's a great teaching experience of basically
what putting out a newspaper is like, which
is what I do every day now.
In a lot of ways, it's really representative
of what it takes to be successful in a really
meaningful career once you graduate college.
The long nights, the studying, the rigorous
demands that I thought almost were unfair
at the time have really helped prepare me
for what it took to be a journalist here,
where you have deadlines, you have multiple
stories a day. You're in an increasingly more
competitive journalism environment where more
and more is demanded of you.
I think one of the coolest things about the
Dow Journalism Program, the opportunity for
networking with really incredible journalists.
I mean, while I was there, we had Naomi Schaefer
Riley come in. She spoke with our class. Talking
with her, I was able to actually pitch her an
idea as a student that ended up published
in The Wall Street Journal while I was still in Hillsdale
It was just this amazing opportunity for me
to be faced with this group of extremely eager
eighteen, nineteen, and twenty-year-olds,
how eager they were to do the work, to ask
the questions that are necessary not only
to be a good journalist but to be a good citizen,
to be a professional.
We're kind of a career development office
for people interested in the media. We work
very hard to help our students land jobs upon
graduation. In fact, everybody who minors
in journalism who wants a job in journalism
pretty much gets one.
I would much rather hire somebody who knows
something and teach them the craft, than find
someone who has only learned the craft but
doesn't know anything. Journalism is a minor
there, so you get to dip your toes in it,
you learn some important things, but at the
same time, the emphasis remains on solid scholarship
and solid citizenship. If you learn the important
stuff, it's that much easier to learn the
journalism stuff.
The framers understood that journalists occupy
a special role in our republic, that's why
the framers in the Bill of Rights, as the
very first amendment to the Constitution protected
the free press and the freedom of speech.
At Hillsdale, as part of the Dow Journalism
Program, they teach the Constitution. They
want young honest reporters to understand
the special place that they occupy in American
society and they do a great job.